[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marieta Slomka guten Abend als
Donald Trump für die
Präsidentschaftswahl 2016 antrat und
sich da ja zunächst den innerparteiliche
Konkurrenten durchsetzen musste gab es
unter den Republikanern warnende Stimmen
er werde die Partei zerstören doch die
meisten wollten das nicht hören selbst
prominente Kritiker hängten am Ende ihr
Fähnchen in den Wind wie weit es nunmehr
mit dieser einst staatstragenden
konservativen Partei gekommen ist lässt
sich derzeit im us-abgeordnetenhaus
beobachten und das liegt in der Ironie
der Geschichte das ist mit dem
verzweifelten Kevin MC jetzt einen
trifft der die Radikalisierung der
Partei eifrig mitmachte und nun selbst
an diesen destruktiven Kräften zu
scheitern
wenigstens beim Eid auf die Flagge sind
sich alle einig Minuten lang lässt Kevin
McCarthy auf sich warten weil hinter den
Kulissen noch Deals ausgelotet werden
aber dann
doch das gleiche wie gestern wieder
nominieren sie ihn trotz der drei
krachenden Niederlage
[Applaus]
ihre schadenfreude ist greifbar bei
meine demokratischen Freunde
missverstehen das was hier passiert das
sieht chaotisch aus aber Demokratie ist
chaotisch
die Rechtsradikalen nominieren Byron
Donalds er wäre wenn gewählt der erste
schwarze Sprecher des Repräsentanten
Hauses recht neu im Kongress näher an
der Basis selbst die Demokraten
applaudieren
dieses Land braucht eine Veränderung
dieses Land braucht Anführer die nicht
die Verkommenheit dieser Stadt hier
widerspiegeln
ein Machtpoker sogar Donald Trump warf
sich für McCarthy in die Bresche stimmt
für Kevin er wird gute Arbeit machen
vielleicht sogar großartige doch selbst
Trump
verlor heute eine weitere Stimme seine
Getreuen nehmen gleich danach bei rin
Donald's ins Gebet könnte er einen Deal
zu den abweichland vermitteln auf einmal
diskutieren Gegner und Anhänger
mccarthies miteinander und ziehen dann
wieder in den parteiinternen Krieg
fast idyllisch dagegen was für eine
Ironie der Präsident gemeinsam mit dem
Republikaner Chef im Senat Joe Biden und
mit mcConnell Weinen Kentucky eine
Brücke ein finanziert aus dem
infrastrukturgesetz solche Partei
übergreifenden Projekte scheinen jetzt
unmöglich angesichts des Dramas im
Capitol
wollen wir noch mit unserem USA
Korrespondenten MRT Wissen sprechen aber
lass uns diese Figur des Mick Carson
noch mal näher ansehen das ist ja schon
interessant dass er so viele
Konzessionen im Vorfeld an die radikalen
Rechten macht die in Posten versprach
und so weiter aber damit überhaupt
nichts erreicht hat
ja das ist so hinter den Kulissen gab es
Gesprächen in den letzten Wochen auch
jetzt in der letzten Nacht wieder und es
soll jetzt in der nächsten Nacht
intensive Gespräche gehen aber er ist
schon geben aber ist schon sehr weit
gegangen er hat angeboten dass man
beispielsweise relativ einfach den
Sprecher stürzen kann mit einem
Misstrauensvotum was fünf Leute im
Grunde am Anfragen müssen jetzt fordern
die sogar das eine Stimme ausreichen
müsste um so einen Misstrauensvotum auf
die Agenda zu setzen sie fordern Posten
sie wollen mitreden bei den Gesetzen im
Plenum selber noch mal schnell Anhänge
Zusätze in diese Gesetzentwürfe einfügen
und das geht mir Kaffee eben zu weit
Basisdemokratie seit zwar prima dahin
müsste man mehr aber diesen Forderungen
nachzukommen würde heißen er würde sich
zur Marionette der rechtsradikalen
machen
und jetzt haben wir erstmal die
Situation dass das amerikanische
Parlament im Prinzip nicht
funktionsfähig ist also nicht das
Repräsentantenhaus
ja das ist so es passiert nichts also
wir sind jetzt gerade im sechsten Wahl
gegangen der wird genauso ausgehen die
wie die fünf Wahlgänge vorher und dann
wird man heute wieder auseinander gehen
und morgen das gleich noch mal versuchen
wenn es keine Einigung geben sollte und
das heißt es gibt keine Ausschussarbeit
kein einziger der Abgeordneten ist
bisher übrigens eingeschworen worden
weil eben dazu erst der Sprecher gewählt
werden muss und dann gibt's eben auch
keine Gesetzesentwürfe oder vorhaben
also die Arbeit im Parlament liegt lahm
vielleicht über Tage vielleicht sogar
länger aber ich muss da jetzt ja auch
ein Speaker her also wie stellen Sie
sich das denn vor wie das weitergeht
ja es muss einer her und ich glaube man
kann sagen da Kevin McCafe ja sogar
Stimmen verliert gerade wieder eine
weniger Stimme bekommen hat dass er
nicht der Sprecher des Hauses werden
wird es muss ein anderer Herr der ist
momentan nicht in Sicht aber so
zerstritten wie die Republikaner sind
selbst wenn sie dann einen Sprecher
hätten wäre der entweder weiter in der
Hand der rechtsradikalen oder würde
versuchen gegen sie sich durchzusetzen
um auch zum Beispiel mit den Demokraten
Gesetzesvorhaben durchzubringen damit
man im Wahlkampf am Ende erfolgreich ist
aber damit macht er sich dann wieder
angreifbar weil er könnte dann jederzeit
gestürzt werden danke schön immer für
diese Einschätzungen aus den USA
in China sollen sich bereits einige
hundert Millionen Menschen mit Corona
infiziert haben seitdem die Regierung
das Virus durchrauschen lässt genau weiß
man es nicht ausgerechnet das Land in
dem die Pandemie entstanden und das
schon damals die Welt zu spät warnte das
Land das vor kurzem noch die weltweit
strengste
anti-corona-politikbetrieb gibt jetzt
kaum mehr Informationen heraus ist schon
immer wieder eindrücklich wie
verantwortlich Diktaturen mit globalen
Themen umgehen in Brüssel wurde heute
darüber debattiert wie in der EU mit
Einreisenden aus China umgegangen werden
soll Christian Rufus berichtet
vor dieser fieber-klinik hier in Peking
möchte man lieber nicht dass ein freies
Kamerateam dreht vielleicht weil vor der
Leichenhalle nebenan immer noch so viel
los ist kann aber eigentlich gar nicht
sein sagt Pekings Führung gestern sein
in ganz China insgesamt fünf Menschen an
Corona gestorben
jemand hat mir erzählt dass die
Regierung diese Zahlen veröffentlicht
hat das ist einstellige Todeszahlen
waren das ist total lächerlich und nicht
glaubhaft wissen Sie unter meinen engen
Verwandten allein sind vier gestorben
von einer Familie
die Krankenhäuser am Limit wie viele
Millionen infiziert sind wie viele
gerade tatsächlich sterben Chinas
Behörde hat aufgehört zu zählen bei der
Einreise nach Europa hat man sich in
Brüssel gerade auf Schnelltests geeinigt
vor dem Flug für alle stichprobenartig
bei Ankunft auf neue Varianten soll auch
getestet werden die Außenministerin
mahnte schon heute Mittag wir müssen die
aktuelle corona-welle aus China sehr
sehr ernst nehmen und da China derzeit
kaum Informationen veröffentlicht ist
eben nicht nur die enge europäische
Abstimmung so wichtig sondern auch die
Zusammenarbeit mit der WHO eben diese
Weltgesundheitsorganisation ist zwar
besorgt über Chinas hohe
Infektionszahlen nach den Daten die man
habe kassiere dort aber die omikon
Variante die kennen wir schon keine
gefährlichere Variante in Sicht sagte
Virologe
man muss sich klar machen dass das Virus
in China auf eine ungeschützte
Bevölkerung trifft und wenn es aus China
raus käme müsste es ja quasi mit einer
Bevölkerung ist aufnehmen die
immunologisch viel besser aufgestellt
ist es ist auch so dass das eine
dreifach-optimierung wäre das Virus
müsste immunologisch besser sein also
auch geimpfte und genesen infizieren es
müsste stärker anstecken sein und dann
als drittes auch noch gefährlicher sein
und dafür gibt es keinen Selektionsdruck
keinen Selektionsdruck also keinen
Anlass für das Virus sich stark
verändern zu müssen denn ommikron hat in
China gerade leichtes Spiel die Haltung
in Brüssel heute trotzdem vorsicht ist
besser als Nachsicht nachdem schon die
USA und auch Italien Frankreich oder
Spanien längst wieder Einreisende aus
China testen ist picking davon nicht
begeistert
Chinas Haltung ist dass die
pandemie-maßnahmen aller Länder
wissenschaftlich fundiert und angemessen
sein sollten und nicht dazu benutzt
werden sollten politische Manipulationen
zu betreiben oder zu diskriminieren
das kommentiert man nicht groß bei der
Kommission corona-tests seien auch keine
einreisebeschränkungen denn jeder aus
China darf wieder kommen in zweieinhalb
Wochen ist chinesisches Neujahr
hauptreise und Urlaubszeit im Reich der
Mitte
das Bundesverteidigungsministerium hat
sich heute zum Zustand der
Schützenpanzer Puma geäußert wir
erinnern uns bei einem bundeswehrmanöver
im Dezember vielen 18 von 18 Fahrzeugen
aus der liar rief sich erstaunt die
Augen für Militärexperten war das nicht
ganz so unerklärlich die Puma Probleme
scheinen gerade so symptomatisch für das
was sind der deutschen und auch der
europäischen Rüstungspolitik schief
läuft dazu gehört zum Beispiel dass man
gerne immer neue Modelle haben will
bitte national produziert und mit lauter
Zusatzfunktionen Porsche Cabrio mit
Dachträger sozusagen
und dann wundert man sich wenn es
erstmal ein Garagenwagen wird Ines
transberichtet
im Werbevideo der Bundeswehr wird der
Puma gefeiert als qualitativer Sprung
für die Einsatzbereitschaft des Heeres
doch aktuell ist er nur bedingt
einsatztauglich 17 der 18 defekten
Schützenpanzer sind zwar repariert doch
ein Schadensbericht stellt ein
differenziertes Bild überwiegend kleiner
und mittlerer aber auch einzelner
schwerwiegender Schäden Fest auch
vermeintlich einfache Ausfälle können im
Gefecht zum Tode führen deswegen muss
das sorgfältig untersucht werden und das
tun wir das klingt ein bisschen nach
Verteidigung der Verteidigungsministerin
denn der Verdacht steht im Raum das
Ministerin Lambrecht zu schnell auf die
Industrie gezeigt hat und zu schnell
nach der pannenreihe Nachrüstung und
Kauf weiterer Pumas ausgesetzt hatte
die Ministerin lag komplett falsch mit
ihrer Ersteinschätzung bei der sie die
Industrie für die Mängel
hauptverantwortlich gemacht hat der
Gegenteil ist der Fall es scheint kleine
und mittlere Mängel gewesen zu sein die
die Bundeswehr selbst nicht in der Lage
war in einer Gefechtssituation sozusagen
zu beheben der gravierendste Defekt ein
Kabelbrand einige Schäden aber sind wohl
schlicht auf Bedienfehler oder
mangelnder Ausbildung zurückzuführen
genaues sagt der Bericht nicht auch
nicht wer Schuld hat eine Truppe die den
Panzer schlecht gewartet hat oder eine
Industrie die ein zuempfindliches Gerät
gebaut hat was ist passiert was ist
einen Maschinen kaputt gegangen wer
trägt dafür die Verantwortung die
Ministerin hatte im Vorfeld ja viel über
ihn Industrie gesprochen über die
Industrie habe ich im Bericht jetzt gar
nichts gefunden also der Vorhang zu und
viele Fragen offen
wirklich klar wird jedoch ohne Beistand
von industrietechnikern kann der
anfällige hochkomplexe Puma nicht in den
Einsatz gehen wenig realitätsnah wenn
sie Soldaten an der Front haben dann
muss so ein System händelbar sein
intuitiv händelbar sein und zuverlässig
sein und das muss jetzt geklärt werden
aber es beweist eben das sehr sehr viel
Technik nicht immer der Weisheit letzter
Schluss ist in der schnellen
Eingreiftruppe der NATO die Deutschland
seit Beginn des Jahres anführt kommt nun
erstmal ein alter bewährter
Schützenpanzer zum Einsatz der Mörder er
kann weniger ist aber robust
der politische
Gesichtsverlust der ist natürlich groß
und das gilt nicht nur für die
Nato-Partner sondern auch für die
Partner die sich möglicherweise überlegt
haben den Puma in Zukunft zu kaufen die
stellen sich natürlich schon die Fragen
was hier in Berlin zurzeit eigentlich so
abgeht ein Spitzentreffen von Industrie
Truppe und Ministerium soll nun klären
wie gefechtstauglich wie kriegstauglich
der Puma tatsächlich ist seine Zukunft
ist nach wie vor offen
diese westerkrawalle mit massiven
Übergriffen auf Einsatzkräfte sorgen
weiter für Diskussionen und die
Förderung nach politischen Konsequenzen
damit beginnen jetzt die Nachrichten
eins Berlins Regierende Bürgermeisterin
gifheim hat einen Gipfel gegen Jugend
Gewalt angekündigt im ZDF sprach sie
sich außerdem für eine schnelle
Bestrafung von Tätern aus an Silvester
hatten vor allem junge Männer Polizei
Feuerwehr und Sanitäter in Berlin und
anderen Großstädten attackiert in der
Hauptstadt ist laut gefallen deshalb vor
allem die Jugend Sozialarbeit gefordert
der deutsche Städte und Gemeindebund
sieht angesichts zahlreicher
Herausforderungen und Belastungen wie
explodierende Energiekosten Inflation
und Rezession die staatliche
Leistungsfähigkeit am Limit
Verbandspräsident Brandl und
Hauptgeschäftsführer Landsberg forderten
einen realistischen Blick so begrüßen
sie zwar die geplante Ganztagsbetreuung
an Grundschulen verweisen aber darauf
dass dafür auch entsprechend Personal
und Räumlichkeiten nötig sein bei der
Aufnahme und Integration von
geflüchteten und Vertriebenen seien
viele Städte und Gemeinden an der Grenze
ihrer Kapazitäten
von den Rüstungsexporten die im
vergangenen Jahr in Deutschland
genehmigt wurden betraf rund ein Viertel
die Ukraine das gab das
Wirtschaftsministerium bekannt insgesamt
erlaubte das Ministerium Exporte im Wert
von 8,36 Milliarden Euro das ist etwas
weniger als der Rekordwert von 2021 nach
der Ukraine kommen die Niederlande die
USA und Großbritannien etwa 90% der
deutschen Rüstungsgüter gingen an enge
Partnerstaaten hieß es in Berlin
frankreich will der Ukraine spätpanzer
vom Typ
amx10rc liefert das habe Präsident
macron dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski zugesagt so der elise-palast
zur Zeitpunkt und Umfang wurden keine
Angaben gemacht
aus Moskau heute neue Angaben zum
ukrainischen Raketenangriff auf eine
Unterkunft russischer Truppen in der
Silvesternacht nicht 63 sondern 89
Soldaten sein bei dem Angriff auf das
Quartier in markiska ums Leben gekommen
so ein Militärsprecher das ukrainische
Militär geht von bis zu 400 Toten aus
und die russische Armee hat eine neue
hyperschallrakete in Dienst gestellt in
einer öffentlichen Zeremonie erklärten
Präsident Putin und
Verteidigungsminister schuigu eine
Fregatte mit der sogenannten
zirkonrakete sei Richtung Atlantik
entsandt worden die Raketen dienen in
erster Linie den Beschuss von Schiffen
wegen ihrer hohen Geschwindigkeit können
sie kaum von der Flugabwehr aufgehalten
werden
energiepolitisch hat uns der
ukraine-krieg ja in einem klassischen
Zielkonflikt gestürzt um Putins Erdgas
in Windeseile zu ersetzen oder verstärkt
wieder zu Kohle und Öl gegriffen und
natürlich ist das nicht das was den
Klimaschutzzielen förderlich ist selbst
das Energie sparen das besser gelangen
als von manchen erwartet konnte das wohl
nicht ausgleichen berichtet
der Ort ein Symbol für den Deutschen
klimakonflikt lützerath in
Nordrhein-Westfalen soll in diesen Tagen
abgebaggert werden die Braunkohle werde
angesichts der Energiekrise dringend
gebraucht sagen Energiekonzern und
schwarz-grüne Landesregierung lützerath
stehe für klimasünden sagt die
Protestbewegung wir werden mit
Sitzblockaden mit Demonstrationen hier
die Bagger und die Polizei stoppen das
ist genau diese Kohle die im Boden
bleiben muss und es ist genau diese
fossile Industrie die wir beenden müssen
jedes Jahr rechnet die Denkfabrik und
Lobby-Organisation agora Energiewende
nach ob Deutschland seine selbst
gesteckten Klimaziele einhält das
Ergebnis für 2022 ist ernüchternd zwar
haben Haushalte und Unternehmen deutlich
weniger Energie verbraucht
-4,7% dennoch bleibt der CO2-Ausstoß mit
rund 761 Millionen Tonnen konstant hoch
unsere Jahresauswertung hat eine
doppelte Überraschung zum einen fällt
der Energieverbrauch auf den niedrigsten
Stand seit der Wiedervereinigung
gleichzeitig sinken aber die
Treibhausgasemissionen nicht Grund dafür
ist wir haben mehr kohleverbraucht und
deswegen stagnieren die Emissionen den
Berechnungen zufolge verfehlt
Deutschland damit wie schon im Vorjahr
sein Ziel zur CO2 Reduzierung die
Energiewirtschaft etwa stößt wieder mehr
CO2 aus im Bereich Wohnen bauen sorgt
Modernisierungsstau für eine zu hohe
CO2-Bilanz und auch der Sektor Verkehr
liegt nach den verkehrsberuhigten
corona-jahren wieder deutlich über den
eigentlich vereinbarten Mengen über eben
diese sogenannten sektorziele streitet
gerade die ampelregierung die FDP will
durchsetzen dass in Zukunft alles
zusammen betrachtet wird ohne
kleinteiligere Vorgaben zum Beispiel für
den Verkehr
es geht ja nicht darum den einzelnen
Sektor sich anzuschauen denn dem Klima
ist es ja vollkommen egal wo das CO2
herkommt wir müssen die Sektoren
zusammen betrachten Verkehr
gebäudesektorindustrie und natürlich
auch den Strombereich die Grünen lehnen
diese Abschaffung der sektorziele
kategorisch ab gleichzeitig sorgt bei
Ihnen ein aktuelles Positionspapier von
Finanzminister Lindner für Aufregung für
die Energiesicherheit sagt er solle man
die Gasförderung per Fracking erlauben
und nochmals über Atomkraft nachdenken
Herr Lindner kann das sagen was er für
richtig erachtet wir sehen uns in der
Linie dessen was die Bundesregierung vor
hat und vor allem auch in der Linie der
deutschen Wirtschaft die nämlich schon
lange verstanden hat dass die Zukunft
erneuerbar ist und dass die Zukunft
nicht Atom heißt und auch nicht Tracking
heißt die selbst ernannte Klima
Regierung verfehlt wohl bisher die
Klimaziele und streitet über die
richtige Klima Politik
morgen gibt es die erste große bunte
länderrunde zur krankenhausreform der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat da ja
großes vor spricht sogar von einer
Revolution das ganze System solle
geradezu auf den Kopf gestellt werden
dass das notwendig ist darüber besteht
weitgehend Einigkeit zu offenkundig sind
ja die Probleme Krankenhäuser die sich
finanziell nur noch mühsam über Wasser
halten falsche Anreize für Behandlungen
und Bettenbelegung durch die sogenannten
faltpauschalen und immer wieder zu wenig
Personal jetzt in der aktuellen
winterwelle mit Corona Influenza und
jeder Menge Erkältungsviren ist das ja
dramatisch sichtbar geworden
insbesondere in den Kinderkliniken
Sibylle Basler berichtet
ein Frühchen kämpft um sein Leben auf
der Neonatologie der Münchner Uniklinik
es hat einen der wenigen Plätze auf der
Station bekommen täglich müssen Andreas
Flemmer und sein Team entscheiden
welches Kind können wir noch übernehmen
und welches nicht so bitter es ist in
diesem reichen Land es reicht hinten und
vorne nicht Personal fehlt sieben
Bettchen stehen deshalb leer dazu die
immensen Kosten für die Ausstattung
Beatmungsgeräte monitoranlagen
spritzenpunkten müssen alle auf die
Bedürfnisse dieser aller kleinsten
Kinder ausgerichtet sein die ständige
Bereitschaft bedeutet auch rote Zahlen
die geplante krankenhausreform soll das
Geld nun besser verteilen dazu werden
Deutschlands Kliniken jetzt in drei
Stufen eingeteilt in kleine überwiegend
ambulante Häuser mittlere Häuser für
kompliziertere Eingriffe und
Maximalversorger wie Unikliniken
Spezialisierung lautet die Devise für
Unikliniken wie großhadern ist die
Reform ein Meilenstein den Fokus ist
mehr auf Qualität der Behandlung und
weniger auf die auf die wirtschaftliche
erlösttrimmung und das ist das gute an
diesem System das Krankenhaus Werneck in
Unterfranken wolfhardt-walde leitet das
Haus mit nur 40 Betten nun fürchtet er
dass es als Verlierer der Reform
hervorgehen könnte die größte Angst habe
ich davor dass wir auf Dauer nicht mehr
das Geld bekommen was wir eigentlich so
Aufrechterhaltung unserer Arbeit
brauchen das heißt dauerhafter Verluste
bis zur Schließung denn Leistungen wie
diese Bandscheiben-OP würden wohl hier
künftig nicht mehr bezahlt etwa 4000
Patienten werden von Belegärzten pro
Jahr operiert mit den unterschiedlichen
Diagnosen jetzt fürchtet man um die
Existenz des Hauses es werden viele
kleine Häuser die hohe Qualität liefern
die hoch anerkannt sind von der
Bevölkerung die werden nicht mehr da
nicht nur kleine Krankenhäuser würden
schließen müssen auch mittlere könnten
Verlierer sein so Klaus Emmerich
ehemaliger Geschäftsführer einer Klinik
für die Häuser befürchte ich das ganz
viel Aufbauarbeit die die Krankenhäuser
der Grund- und Regelversorgung in den
Regionen geleistet haben komplett
umsonst war das müssen die alles wieder
aufgeben die rohmetklinik im
oberbayerischen Wasserburg ein Neubau
mit Notfallmedizin und einer der größten
Abteilungen für Gefäßchirurgie seit drei
Wochen ist der OP in Betrieb das
medizinische Personal die Ausstattung
auf höchstem Niveau greift die Reform
werden die Folgen für unser Haus wurde
das bedeuten dass wir diese Eingriffe
nicht mehr durchführen können weil es
den künftigen Anforderungen nicht mehr
entspricht es hier zu wenig Fachbereiche
und Intensivbetten gibt dafür sind die
Strukturen hier allerdings nicht
vorhanden und damit könnten wir
eigentlich nicht so weitermachen wie wir
wollen
das ist sehr bitter weil hier ein
dreistelliger Millionenbetrag vom
Freistaat und auch von unserem Träger
investiert worden ist rund 1.900
Krankenhäuser gibt es in Deutschland zu
viele da sind sich die Experten einig
nur welches Haus muss schließen keine
leichte Aufgabe diese krankenhausreform
jetzt der Blick auf die Wirtschaft
unserer Sendung Heinz und zwar auf den
Autoabsatz in Deutschland der ist 2022
nach zwei rückgängernden Folge wieder
gestiegen gerade bei Elektroautos legte
die Nachfrage zu Stefan im Moment der
stand bei der Elektromobilität ja
tatsächlich wurden im vergangenen Jahren
Deutschland erstmal wieder mehr neue
Fahrzeuge auf die Straße gebracht als in
den doch sehr rückläufigen corona-jahren
zuvor der dezember brachte sogar eine
Premiere erstmals überholten
Elektroautos in diesem Monat die
Zulassungen von Verbrennern von den
insgesamt 2,65 Millionen Neuzulassungen
in Deutschland waren im vergangenen Jahr
rund
833.000 Elektrofahrzeuge 22% mehr als
noch im Vorjahr über 170.000 wurden
allein im Dezember zugelassen der
dezember-effekt geschuldet gewesen sein
denn seit Anfang Januar ist es vorbei
mit der großzügigen Förderung staatliche
Prämien sind verkürzt und Hybridmodelle
fallen jetzt ganz aus der Förderung
viele Käufer dürften also zum Jahresende
versucht haben noch die Prämie zu
ergattern nun könnte der Boom von
Elektroautos in diesem Jahr vorerst
ausgebremst werden denn auch die
steigenden Strompreise dürften Käufer
abschrecken zudem mangelt es vor allem
in den Städten noch immer an
schnellladesäulen ja und diese
beeindruckende Kurve spricht für sich
den dritten Tag in Folge deutliche
Gewinne beim DAX es ist die Hoffnung auf
eine nachlassende Inflation die hier die
Kurse antreibt Stefanie berrett vielen
Dank
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 19 29 31 34 37 47 und die
Superzahl 0 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im zdf-
zum Wintersport bei der Tour de Ski in
Oberstdorf kam Langläuferin Katharina
Hennig beim 20 km Freistil
Verfolgungsrennen auf den 9 Platz der
Sieg ging an die Schwedin Freda Karlsson
die auch in der Gesamtwertung führt
hennigfield da heute vom 15 auf den 7
Platz zurück
bei der Vierschanzentournee war heute
der dritte Wettbewerb in Innsbruck bei
den Deutschen sprengen gab es die beste
Platzierung für Philipp Reimund auf Rang
13 gewonnen hat heute David Kubatzki aus
Polen der in der Gesamtwertung führende
Norweger Grana Rüdt wurde Zweiter
steht vor seinem zweiten Sprung unter
Druck der Gesamtführende der
Vierschanzentournee liegt nach dem
ersten Durchgang nur auf Rang 6 und
braucht einen richtig guten Sprung und
der gelingt ihm mit 133 Metern fliegt er
heute mit Abstand am weitesten doch für
den Sieg reicht es nicht den holt sich
der Pole David Kubatzki dem führenden
nach dem ersten Durchgang reichen bei
schlechteren Windbedingungen
121,5 m zum Tageserfolg im
gesamtglasmoor ist Kubatzki trotzdem
weiter deutlich Hintergründe vor dem
Finale in Bischofshofen ist der Norweger
der große Favorit auf den Sieg dieser
Vierschanzentournee bester Deutscher im
gesamtklassner ist Andreas Wellinger auf
Rang 8
das war es von uns im heute-journal
gleich geht es weiter mit dem ersten
Teil von Maren nostrum eine große ZDF
Reportage über den Mittelmeerraum der
auf 47.000 km Küstenlinie europäische
afrikanische und nahe östliche
Kulturlandschaften und fast mit
überraschenden Einblicken etwa beim
Besuch eines Weingutes in Libanon
und um 0:55 meldet sich den Christopher
Wehrmann mit unserem heute schnell
Update bis morgen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das alte Jahr ist
vorbei das neue ist gestartet auch viel
zu mild und das letzte Jahr 2022 war das
wärmste seit 1881 mit dem Jahr 2018
zusammen ja und wir sehen hier die
Aufreihung aller Jahre seit 1881 und die
Tendenz ist eindeutig steigend ja und
die der letzte Balken das ist das Jahr
2022 hier eindeutig sichtbar zum mild
auch in den nächsten Tagen denn es kommt
von Westen her milde Luft das Sturmtief
hier das verabschiedet alle Sicherheit
und bringt ebenfalls Regen in der Nacht
schon verbreitet und dazu auch dichte
worden und teilweise stürmische auch
Sturmböen bis ins Flachland und das bei
Temperaturen von vier gerade im
Alpenrand und 11 Grad im Südwesten eine
recht mildenacht morgen gibt's weiterhin
viele Schauer im Osten Deutschland ganz
ja und dazu kräftigen Wind wieder
stürmische Böden auch mal Sturmböen
dabei sonst lockert es mal auf bevor zum
Abend dann von Westen neuer Regen
aufkommen bei höchsten Temperaturen von
8 Grad Richtung Küsten und 14 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands ziemlich mild mit
das Stichwort auch für die nächsten Tage
Freitag viele Wolken mit Regen 6 bis 14
Grad Samstag bis 13 Grad relativ trocken
Sonntag neue Regen und etwas kühler bei
5 bis 11 Grad damit ein schönen Abend